we thought we were indestructible the
Lords of iron we swore we would do
anything to protect the last city some
of us paid the ultimate price Alex new
house destiny rise of iron was revealed
to us this morning in a bungee
livestream at Trent yes it was yes it
was and it sort of showed us what
destiny has in store for the sort of
next six months or so so we're going to
go through the what we know what we
learned and the trailer that we saw and
sort of give our some impressions of it
so Alex initial thoughts is it does seem
to be shaping up as a pretty big content
expansion and I mean the stuff that
showing off seems super cool and super
different which is really important to
me yeah I have to say I wasn't that
exciting it wasn't that exciting to me I
wasn't blown away by it but it seems
like there's going to be enough content
there for me to sort of get back into
destiny it seems taken King like style
so let's go go through some of the
specifics so the setting you mentioned
way more natural environment there lots
of snow there's like a mountain yeah
it's a lot less alien ish yeah it's on
the Cosmodrome or not is the Cosmodrome
is on earth it's on earth the the rise
of iron setting is also on earth I think
that's super cool you know when you
think of Destiny you think of big alien
constructs and alien enemies and just
things that aren't earth-like and this
is really getting grounded into
something that seems like it's worth
like yeah so they emphasized a lot of
the law and sort of the the origins of
the iron lords who run the iron banner
tournament and they're talking about a
lot about a wall that falls and sort of
a new enemy that comes from behind that
wall yeah so if you remember board
Saladin runs the iron banner and he
looks like he's running you know the
quest to rise Viron as well yeah and the
lore is basically the iron Lords were
keeping the plague out and then the iron
Lawrence died and now the plague which
are these mutated forms of the fallen
enemies have broken through the wall and
have infected this entire new zone yeah
and they look really cool i must say we
only got a glimpse of maybe
one of the buses in a few of the sort of
low level mobs but they look like some
cyberpunk like robot things which is a
nice variation and I think I mean it is
slightly disappointing that the two new
enemies they've introduced so far in the
life of Destiny have both been sort of
just changed forms of old enemies but
the plagued fallen do look really cool
they like walking on stilts and have
these crazy like knives and they
actually look interesting as opposed to
taken who would just like black and
white versions of existing enemies
essentially yeah they do show off a
couple of the bosses one of them you
didn't think looked great yeah the first
sort of it seemed like it was a strike
boss or something like that it wasn't a
very particularly interesting dude he
was kind of like a robot thing with like
metal plating with like a rail gun or
some sort I wasn't too went to him but
what they did show that was cool was the
what we assume is a raid boss which
looked like this giant mechanical
contraption this like sort of um you
know construction vehicle that was like
chasing after six guardians and it
looked like a really fun encounter we
you know one of those things we just run
like hell and like try and shoot back as
quickly as you can when you ever get the
opportunity okay and let's talk about
some of the new weapons obviously they
showed off a flaming hammer so not
exactly like the Titans um flaming
hammer from taking king but more like a
sort of crota style weapon yeah if you
remember the swords from the base game
that you would get in in specific
missions it's sort of like that it's an
encounter specific weapon but it looks
badass like it's this massive flaming
battle axe and you just it like they
show the character coming in swinging
with it and it looks really cool and
looks really fun uh new almost sets we
got a glimpse of some of the new ama
sets and your guns they kind of just
look like colorful things to me yeah and
I mean one of the best things destiny
does is the armor just how unique it all
looks and how colorful and crazy the
exotic armor sets look and this is no
different and in terms of weapons we
should probably address the elephant in
the room which is the return of the gala
horn yeah alright what do you what do
you think about this okay so what
they're doing is they
making the gala horn available for all
players to forge or construct through a
quest and if you preorder it you can get
the iron Gallo horn which is basically a
monochromatic themed version of that so
the gala horn in the base game was just
exceptionally rare rocket launcher that
was overpowered you know you shoot a
rocket at home in and then it split in
two eight more rockets and you know do
extra damage and it was only available
for purchase on the very first week of
Destiny's release and sort of its its
rarity became almost mythical so this
was like the this was the the shining
light that you were always chasing I'm
in destiny like if you got a gal horn
you were you're set yeah that was the
gun that you use and it was very much
like the best weapon in the game it was
fun just yet I think body emits that and
I the one disappointing thing about this
to me at least is in the twist tree and
they show that montage of everyone
getting the gallery won't drop and
freaking out and then they're like oh
yeah if you preorder you get it yeah you
know that they're making the best gun in
the game into a pre-order bonus yeah
that's right it's it definitely loses a
any kind of special aura that might have
had when you know that it is a very
easily attainable weapon and hey at
least you know the gala horn is still
super fun to use it's still super fun to
use and looks really cool something the
best thing in the game absolutely um Oh
what do you think of about the social
space the social space I quite like like
we were saying before the natural
environments are really nice and they
were in the live stream they were
emphasizing how much of us a rustic sort
of feel they were going for because you
know the towers very clinical and you
know futuristic and the reef was kind of
like industrial I guess this one came
seems to be a more calming like rocky
space with a mausoleum you're mentioning
before it's a mausoleum to the iron
Lawrence that died in a kind of question
that we don't really know about yet but
that's the social space my I think it
looks really cool my mom concern is now
we're going to have three social spaces
yeah as well that's a lot of flying back
to ol bed yeah
that was not is not a fun part of
destiny and I think a lot of people
would probably prefer if all the vendors
were in one place like as it is some are
split between the reef and the tower and
it's kind of a pain to have to fly to
the tower than flight of the reef and
then you know probably fight back to the
tavern and one more thing we should
mention is that they're not releasing
this expansion on last gen consoles so
ps3 and 360 although they did have
destiny in the its first iteration and
it did have they they did have all those
expansion packs they're not putting it
on those old consoles it's just the new
stuff what do you think about that this
will be super disappointing for the
people who were playing on 360 and ps3
which is a substantial number of people
but at the same time it's about time
that they move to the ps4 and Xbox it
needs to be a point in the console
generation where we need to move on i
mean look peaceful and phasic steep
enough for 10 years you know they would
they need to say no a certain point I I
have no particular sort of strong
feelings about this bit right and with a
lot of Bundy's resources probably
directed towards Dustin need to you know
they can only direct the resources at so
many different things and taking out the
360 and ps3 which is probably a pretty
significant problem with in development
at this point yet gives them more leeway
to actually focus on this I'm guessing
you know although it will sting for
people who play destiny on ps3 and 360
you know they must have been some sort
of research that point you did that said
no like eighty percent of our player
bases are all on that as well or they're
not buying expansion will they not
buying in Spanish there's something like
that so we didn't get too many details
but we got enough of a taste of rise of
iron hopefully we'll find out more at e3
next week Alex yeah i'm looking forward
to it rise of iron comes out on sep
tember 20th for xbox one and ps4 and i'm
really looking forward to getting my
hands on it yeah I'm really looking
forward to getting the district put it
back together yeah I'm disappointing
there's no dogs though me too I mean
they do show wolves and the new shovels
in the trailer but it there's still hope
yet yeah
you